all right well speaking of the outdoors
hopefully there's not too much rain
today but i love a great meal at a
beautiful restaurant patio actually my
favorite is americana at desert shores
if you've never been there you feel like
you're on vacation but the strip has
several great spots to choose from and
tomorrow is national eat outside day
rocky is live at the link with more on
how you can celebrate hi rocky
hey jillian yes okay the vibes are set
here at the link okay you've got the
music you've got people enjoying and
you've got food right chef michael yeah
we have tons of food here virgil's best
thing to eat the
barbecue on outdoor dining day right on
beautiful patios okay so we're going to
come back to talk about food in a minute
but first let's get more information
about the link because this is actually
if you didn't know fun fact the very
first promenade on the las vegas strip
right and this is our gm tanya so you're
going to tell us more about the link
yeah
we you're right uh by far the most
walking and patios in one spot on the
las vegas strip and in las vegas we have
12 patios in our few blocks here with
foods from
everywhere we have like we talked about
virgils at the barbecue we have mexican
we have gelato we have pizza we have
deli it's a one-stop shop for outdoor
fun and like they said 12 patios this
one is virgil's so tell us what's on the
menu here let's talk about this food
right now in a couple seconds so we have
a little regional barbecue here at
virgos we have healthy salad with some
grilled shrimp our famous smoked chicken
wings our pig out meant for two to share
barbecue chicken pulled pork brisket
ribs some mac and cheese that's to die
for i'm listening but you know the test
is mac and cheese you gotta fill the
belly so first so baked beans
some cocktails at the end by tanya and a
little bit of key lime pie oh my gosh
this is delicious okay so i'm gonna pour
some drinks and come back in the 4 p.m
show but tomorrow celebrate national eat
outside day here at the link or look up
anywhere in las vegas you can go
somewhere and have a great meal outside
i'll send it back to you
thank you rocky that food looks
delicious have a rib for me we'll see
you in the 4pm newscast and